alright here we go another one
hey Jack class not the house hi mommy
I'm Samuel E and this is hey Seymour
pumpkin seed Center it's a 4-bedroom
house he's on rates for players and
parents and I think they would be open
to offers on this one well so let's a
look around looking for HMOs so three
three three bedrooms two reception rooms
seen it seen a couple got a few more to
see as well I've seen one or two that
really fits the bill for a second we're
looking for so I'm quite close to
business Chuck some efficient and secure
yeah okay cool
okay this is Lodge Road in Birmingham
let's have a little look around
so we've got here the downstairs room
this is reception room which will be
turned into a nice big bedroom with a
partition wall just right through here
so you've got a sailfin tang room so
here's what your kicking leg which again
is nice good condition solid walls
double eyes so this is fantastic kitchen
again in really good condition wouldn't
have to spend a penny on this solid most
of spacious with a bathroom for a Kia
which would be a communal bathroom as
well so so far pretty good we've got one
room downstairs but a good-sized kitchen
and a bathroom Electra space here which
is always nice for ancient as well so
let's have a look upstairs
so far all this needs to be counted but
I'm very poor in addition okay this is
only the first room yes really big door
deporting Brenda see
this is the smallest room we have what
you like it doesn't meet the requirement
so this room is going to be too small to
enter which is usually a problem we get
around it right so we've got a couple
here you've got a big room and
configuring downstairs and then we run
upstairs again a lot of dead storage
down there nice the top a lovely
bathroom with a toilet and a shower so
that's fantastic
so let's get cornstalks because this is
not for this is not for me this is the
carpet let's get coffee we don't know
it's brilliant
um with this you just come up with this
idea just now actually because we were
struggling to see how we can get five
rooms but by bringing the door forward
and the one that we've just seen the
last one we just seen now when we
initially walked in we thought we can
only get four words out of it but um
Samuel is good eye for prophesying just
actually seen that we can actually get
prior to hearing this rather than four
rooms out of it by some sticking up the
stud wall by the entrance this is good
enough space for the community area and
downstairs where the kitchen is could
also be a green area as well so what's
all the figures on figures work I think
we're going to achieve about four
hundred quid
room so those two grand brats so next
looking around about 1,500 quid after
bills and stuff and what with a deposit
on the house posit well 20 grands on
paper was it return on investment about
fifteen fifty percent or so awesome good
job man oh yeah great
by the way that one's your call is being
recorded for training purposes I'm all
about so quit yeah you did okay that's
great right we just got a really good
news from one of our agents we just had
enough accepted by kills just before
close of business today for 105 500 for
five-bedroom HMO and very close to the
sound sensor five good-sized rooms as
well um condition of the house is
actually bang gone we don't really need
to do much to it to be honest with you
so happy days thanks oh my god man